call of duty war zone it's been out a
few seasons and it has some great ideas
like the gulag but it also has a lot to
learn from other battle royale games
like fortnite and apex
in this video we're going to talk about
11 things call of duty warzone needs to
change to make it a better game
ahead of next season let's do this
number one team drop what in the
skydiving hell is up with having a squad
leader that picks a drop point and then
players bail out individually and
scatter to the wind
apex has the ideal system that allows
the team leader to drop the squad all at
once so at least everybody ends up on
the same part of the map
anyone who wants to peel off still can
so you get the best of both worlds
number two expanded ping system are you
the strong silent type there are many
times when you really need your team to
watch a specific area or not do
something
or split cash to buy somebody back or
any large number of very important and
time sensitive things and you can't
communicate it without being on mic
enemy movement a robust ping and
response system really helps those who
want to communicate
apex does a great job and warzone should
learn from it it feels real bad
not to at least be able to say thank you
to fellow players
don't mention it number three aggressive
band hammer we need a better ping system
in part because many players have good
reason to be off mic
games like rainbow six siege have
mastered the art of the band for toxic
behavior racist names and anything else
that makes their game less welcoming
one call of duty studio infinity ward
recently tweeted that they will crack
down
and hand out permanent bans for repeat
offenders which is a great idea this has
been a problem
for many many years i'm going to keep
this one here until we actually see it
implemented because if you want to play
warzone we want you to feel welcomed and
play alongside you
number four that main menu confusing
interface aside
a few of us in the office have had the
experience on playstation 4 where the
main menu spins up our console's fans to
an alarming speed we've even had our
console shut down from overheating
because of the main menu
at this stage we'd probably settle for a
simple text based menu that doesn't make
your ps4 scream in agony over the screen
where your character
walks infinitely towards something
fortnite never did us like that
number five run faster fist out we've
had it good with movement in apex for
far too long to go back when that gas
cloud is closing in and you're carrying
heavy weapons that reduce your run speed
to john woo levels of
you really need to be able to put your
weapons away and run faster
like significantly faster it's true that
there are ways to build this with double
time and a knife but we want it
all the time number six events it may
just not have happened yet but we were
hoping season four would have character
drama and huge map
changes nukes going off and unique
challenges so far we've
opened a few bunkers been stuck on a
frozen winter map through the summer
sold a bunch of cold winter themed items
we get it
someone loves winter it's just that
fortnite has been doing amazing map
altering events
and you had to be there moments for
years now it's hard to get excited for
characters we know nothing about give us
the good stuff the animated shorts the
stories outside of the game
there are leaks that season 5 might
finally deliver on some of this
and we're ready number 7 armor the
number of folks here at gamespot would
like to see the game's armor system
change
the current armor causes players to
waste plates because it's limited to
filling or topping off one of three bars
instead it should give you a fixed
number of armor points the full
50 per plate preferably and potentially
spill over from one armor bar
into the next we could also use a bit
more variety in terms of
armor types and rarity number eight
teachable challenges
one of the best games of all time
titanfall it's just facts
had a system of challenges that forced
you to get good with each weapon
those challenges were based on showing
the player what a gun was made to do
far too many challenges in warzone are
simply chores or have nothing to do with
the weapon blueprint that they unlock
we're talking even simple stuff like
teaching players to make sniper kills
from the edge of the gas
or experiment with different rockets for
different situations while we're here
some of the challenges are still just
broken
and that can be frustrating overall the
rewards for warzone challenges just
aren't very good and that needs to
change number nine
improved climbing system far too many
times you'll be on the run from the gas
and get hung up on cliffsides or rocks
when it comes to terrain there isn't a
good way to tell
what is and isn't climbable and there's
nothing worse than getting got
because your ankle snagged it'd be nice
if players could reliably understand
what can and can't be scaled in the heat
of battle number 10
golf masks equipping the gas mask should
be a one time thing
the automatic animation that plays while
taking the mask off near the edge of the
gas
messes with gun play and gets players
killed number 11
balance man this is a tricky one to give
credit where it's due there have been
plenty of balance changes like nerfing
the growl
and making loadout drops more expensive
it's just that there isn't a lot of room
for creativity with perks in the final
circles if you don't have cold blooded
to stay off thermal sniper scopes or eod
so you don't get vaporized by c4
and rpgs you're at a huge disadvantage
we'd like to see fewer dominant tactics
and more risk reward when it comes to
loadout creativity
in general keep up the good work
infinity ward so what are your ideas on
balance and how to improve warzone what
just sticks in your cry when you play
let us know in the comments below if
your ideas are great we might make
another video also don't forget to check
out our gamespot merch store
at store.gamesbot.com store purchases
will be used through the summer to
benefit black lives matter and covid 19
direct relief charities
thanks for watching